[Music]
good morning Hank it's Monday February
19th Presidents Day Hankow is
brotherhood 2.0 resident mathematician
Daniel Biss Daniel's here because his
brother Jonathan is playing a concert at
Carnegie Hall oh and speaking of
concerts I've had a lot of fun reading
and listening to and watching all of the
responses to your video survey it turns
out that our viewers by and large had
terrible taste in music when they were
children let's just go over some of
their first concerts in sync Paula Abdul
Chicago
Huey Lewis and the news the new kids on
the block the Spice Girls the Oak Ridge
Boys LaToya Jackson LaToya Jackson who
goes to a LaToya Jackson concert dude
why Jackson ever even make music I
thought she was just a stripper but a
couple of our viewers first concerts
were pretty frakkin awesome Lauryn Kay
went to see the Dead Milkmen one of our
favorite bands and she would definitely
be the winner for awesomest first
concert were it not for Christopher
whose first concert was at the state
fair over and featured Weird Al Yankovic
opening for the three remaining Monkees
but the most disturbing thing about your
first concert question is that two
Brotherhood 2.0 viewers have apparently
never been to a concert Hank I think
it's vitally important that we get
Melissa and Amy to a concert as soon as
possible and that's why I am proposing
the creation of the Brotherhood 2.0
concert scholarship fund for Melissa and
Amy and also possibly other Brotherhood
2.0 viewers who have not been to
concerts the name is unwieldy I think we
need to work on that anyway I am going
to give $20 to this scholarship fund I
hope that you will match my pledge Hank
the other question I really liked was
the question about how you have to
invent your own question and then answer
it I wanted to answer some of my
favorite questions that other people
posed Kelly Fineman asks if you could
own a house in any country in the world
other than the US where would it be
Ireland Ali Carter asks
is your new book going to be worth all
the effort and finally Laura asks where
is the weirdest place you've ever
brushed your teeth good question I get
you the black hair
[Music]
Hank I'll see you tomorrow